talal bin oui votre altesse vous m'aviez
dit d'écrire sur les amours au bureau
donc fait une sextape et donc vous êtes
viré c'est pour moi je crois que vous
êtes tombé non j'ai un cancer des
testicules mon bazar est destiné aux
poubelles de l'éternité mon cher tu t'es
trompé de salle opus suivants quelque
part c'est juste conneries d'exercice je
crois qu'on était censé faire la liste
de toutes les personnes avec qui on
avait eu un rapport est entouré les
endroits secrets car tu dois en tournée
dans tous ces endroits
c'est pas une mauvaise idée en fait
c'est une idée j'ai rencontré un garçon
il a cancer si j'essayais de revivre mes
histoires sexuelles
ça va être lui et moi faisant l'amour à
chaque étape du voyage est surprenante
parce que j'ai vraiment besoin de ce
boulot
tu peux repasser sur toutes les
aventures avec moi tous ont été ravis
t'es pas censés ne pas avoir de rapport
et éclater une dernière fois parce qu'on
n'est même pas vraiment ces bombes est
qu il faut que tu y retournes pas autre
chose c'est que on dirait que tu l'as
trouvé dans un vide greniers c'est ça
mais un vide greniers perdu au fond des
bois d'accord c'est une antiquité une
fois que ça c'est notre bible hu
toutes ces croix en iran mais sans faire
ça voilà je suis sur les deux me prouve
qu'ils ont rapporté qu'il 169,69 regard
de la route tu te plait je veux des post
it like pendant le voyage des notes
quotidiennes sur comment cet homme gère
la maladie et comment le sexe et l'amour
évoluent avec l'âge et la maturité que
j'essayais d'oublier
je suis terrifiée se rendre compte que
tu as peut-être un problème est que tu
sais pas comment le résoudre
ça fait vraiment peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou on est là c'est la maison de mes
parents
bienvenue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]